the path of the righteous man is beset
on all sides by the inequities of the
selfish and the tyranny of evil men
blessed is he who in the name of charity
and goodwill Shepherds the weak through
the valley of darkness for he is truly
his brother's keeper and the finder of
lost children and I will strike down
upon thee with great vengeance
those who attempt to poison and destroy
my brothers and you will know I lay my
vengeance
[Applause]
[Music]
children when they see you walking down
the street they don't know there is
countless elevator rides I'll be in the
elevator in a in a mother and child will
get on and the mother will say it's
woody try to explain no their voice is
recorded and the actor who is the voice
this is the actor make the kids just
don't get it at all they said where's
the vest where's the cowboy hat you're
not very tall and so I say hmm all right
close your eyes I think a lot just just
close your eyes so the kid away
[Applause]
now when actors do films like that you
know you guys you know what your look at
you because you've seen films like that
because like okay it's gonna be amazing
but what did you think you were looking
at did you think it was going to be that
I can tell you what I was talking at and
and you know it looks pretty it looks
simple enough but actually what I'm
looking at is Steven Spielberg with a
big long stick with a tennis ball at the
air just like this you know you have to
look as spam master class in amazement
now I'm going to ask Miranda a question
and I think I know the answer would you
like to do a bit of acting with sam
neill no okay who do we create the look
of amazement so Becky you look over the
two of you look I've got props in Jenna
I've got props I've got I've got I've
got I've got the Laura Dern leaf you've
got as much res little there as you want
to put on there you go okay
so Perry okay and at the end when they
when they're looking suitably amazed
it's slowing traffic down
stupid things brought them back if you
using your vocal training do a little
bit of dinosaur eat a bit of dinosaur
toys measurably actually do it can you
endure at this yes if we start the music
right behind you because you see you're
looking behind the camera yeah this is
the way because I'm only doing a better
so it's a very small dinosaurs you know
it'll it'll into into lakes that's a
camera right yeah
[Music]
how are you doing
[Laughter]
that's very good that's very helpful I'm
starting the music I'm not being read by
tennis-ball
about you to queue for sound okay let me
say actually
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
[Applause]
so we're sitting here like a couple of
regular fellows I mean you do what you
do I do what I gotta do if I'm there and
I gotta put you away I won't like it but
if it's between you and some poor
bastard whose wife you're gonna turn
into a widow brother you are going down
[Music]
[Applause]
Michael man cuts back to the esteemed
gentleman at the end of the sofa what if
you do got me boxed in I'm not gonna put
you down
living face to face yeah but I will not
hesitate not for a second that's my
gravity mmm so what is I mean because
some movies they you know they do it in
different ways so how do they achieve it
on this it's a few different ways I mean
sometimes we were on a wire 80 feet in
the air other times you were on the end
of a gimbal like a seesaw and other
times I know you
mm-hmm you show you one leg move yeah
yeah sometimes it was very high-tech I
would stand on one leg nope and sort of
float around I hear you're very good can
you show us could you show us
are you sure I mean it's very difficult
yeah no let's see you let's say we put
the musical foot to music on some room
Thanks oh here she goes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
very good does that for two and a half
don't you see it now
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah
oh I love security kisses
she's you murder
that's not even very good no he's having
we're having breakfast and suddenly he
starts coughing right and he can't stop
coughing
and then suddenly if something starts to
burst at his chest and exactly you were
completely eat in the end he's in
terrible pain
we're going a bit hysterical yes okay so
your treasure on this louver leg the
trash
[Music]
okay okay screaming and maybe moving
backward
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
never seeing that felt right
like a Tyrannosaurus Rex I bet no one
has ever seen it from this angle
wanna get out changed in the landscape
but one of the things was sort of derek
zoolander gave us the the selfie face i
guess he did though he existed before
the selfie actually existed i mean when
we made the first movie there was no
phone cameras didn't really exist
because I remember they sort of emerged
about 11 11 years ago we made a movie 14
years ago so but he it felt like Derek
needed a camera in front of his face
because the look that he does is
basically the look that people seem to
do when they take a selfie now but
Bernie even you do it now me yeah like
well I do it I do it yeah well lately
because we've been doing the movie and
or we'll go to a premiere somebody up
people say hey can you do blue steel or
people look so I'm just like trained to
do it and then somebody will say hey can
you take a picture and I'll just you
didn't do blue steel but do you get
asked for blue steel oh I do and I would
try for a couple years to say but that's
not my character and then I just gave up
and I started doing my blue stick let's
see it please well mine doesn't sound
like fingerprints but give me a
countdown one
[Applause]
make your kids really jealous that is if
you just posed with a lightsaber with
thin that would actually make em very
Jeff do it do it I've got one I've got
one in Manchester United at red you know
I really do I really don't where's the
blue one again okay there's the blue one
and actually and here's the thing
because you're in is that you're in the
new King Arthur film I am just a small
part yeah have you done some sort
training okay
you get that work can we not kill Kylie
now there's a way so basically to turn
this on you push you push that thing
that one up okay you've got on David
Beckham you've got your match
I just wanted to meet you
now I suppose they'll be a whole new
generation of kids who fall in love with
this Mary Poppins and so Emily are your
kids how are they with it well I think
um I mean my youngest my two year old
has the sort of attention span of a fly
so she watches the trailer but hazel
who's almost five has seen it and just
absolutely loved it and sort of wants to
talk about it all the time now and yeah
that was really weird
if your mother is Mary Poppins I do
think she's see I think she just thinks
it's normal she's like well that's what
this is what Sunny's mummy does and this
is what my mummy does you know it's just
sort of like quite conversational for
her is it gonna help or hinder
discipline at home Oh hinder really yeah
I think so
because she knows she already knows I
can't fly she's not what she's paid but
she did ask me to do the voice the other
day just out of nowhere because she was
quite sort of impassive watching the
film just sort of didn't just sort of
didn't reveal much of what she felt and
then the other day she goes do your
she's American of course sounds American
she good she good she goes do your Mary
Poppins voice and I go spit-spot and off
we go and she goes where I say to the to
the dolphin no no not yet and now the
two of them go no not yet
[Laughter]
[Music]